hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game uh from day three
of the ftx crypto cup the preliminaries
is hikarna kamura versus
alireza firuja and we said that we were
going to cover one more game before we
check out the standings and who
qualified for the actual event uh
because out of the 16 people that start
in the preliminaries only eight uh go
uh to play the main event uh so this is
a really nice one
and uh there were a lot of games to
choose from i decided to show this one
uh since it's uh well there is a reason
to it uh so
let's just check it out uh so he car
with the white pieces opens with
d4 uh we have knight to f6 c4 and now
c5 going for the benoni defense this is
only one of the reasons i decided to
show this game
we have d5 and now b5 going for the
benko gamut
that's another reason i decided to show
this game we have c
captures on b5 and now a6 happily uh
giving up
more pawns this is how this is played b
captures on a6 and now
g6 preparing to find cattle the dark
square bishop
uh we have knight to c3 and now bishop
to g7 we have g3 and here
just castle so this is all been played
before nothing out of the ordinary here
knight to f3 and now queen to a5
usually uh well most of the times
black will just capture this pawn but
this is a very interesting line queen to
a5
now you will have some threats against
this knight for example you can just
capture here and then if queen captures
you can capture with the bishop and then
if pawn captures then the queen can
capture then you can capture this rook
so there are some very nasty threats
here in the position so here just bishop
to d2 by hikaru
and now d6 we have bishop to g2
and now the position has been reached
before but every time
this position has been reached the pawn
was captured either by the knight or by
the bishop
but here we have knight b to d7 and it
is now uh as of move 10
we have a completely new game so let's
see how he car deals with this so
delaying
uh the recapture of the a6 spawn uh we
have castles uh
and now knight to b6 so there's
additional pressure on the d5 pawn now
we have queen to c2
now asking uh what do you want to play
here uh the thing is if you
try and capture this pawn now with
something like captures then we just
capture it and you can't recapture
because the queen is hanging so that's
out of the question so instead we have
just queen captures an a6
uh you want to capture it upon either
way but this way
at least you get away from the bishop on
d2
uh here we have e4 now cementing this
pawn on d5 and now
knight to c4 putting pressure on this
bishop here
we have b3 uh chasing the the knight
away
and now comes knight captures on d2 we
have knight captures on d2
and now knight to g4 so here a lot of
pressure and you have to be very careful
uh you could try a lot of things but
you know that this bishop for example
could come to d4 and it's going to be
very very interesting
one thing you could do is something like
h3 95 and then
f4 but it's uh very ugly you have to
calculate what happens after queen to d3
now you offer a queen trade
and this is all perfectly fine for black
so here uh instead hikaru went with a4
right away
uh but this says uh well this just
blunders upon and alireza uh spots it uh
right away he plays queen to a5 now
there's a double attack on the knight
here
and you have to defend it we have rook
ate the c1 makes sense as you want to
uh well get the rook away from a1 and
you also don't want to move this rook
and allow something like bishop to d4 so
here we have bishop to a6
exactly what alireza is trying to
achieve now if hikaru moves the rook
then
let's say rook after d1 bishop to d4 and
that's game over there is no defending
this position
so instead uh after bishop to a6 we have
knight to b5
now blocking this bishop so you don't
have to move the rook and also if you
bring the bishop in
uh doesn't really it doesn't really
matter because the rook is on f1
so here bishop captures spawn captures
and queen captures
and by uh by just you know playing
normal moves alireza has won a pawn
uh as that a for push by hikaru was a
bit premature better was to just kick
away the knight and go into that final
line that we've shown
so here we have h3 knight to e5 and now
only now rook after d1 that we rook the
a3 now piling up on this spawn
and now bishop to f1 attacking elitist's
queen queen to b4
and now queen to c3 uh offering a queen
trade but all it is i'm not interested
he just brings the queen back
queen to b7 and now queen to e3
uh we have rook to a tune you could
bring the other rook over to the a-file
that's also perfectly fine but uh
rook to a8 is what alireza chooses he
wants to infiltrate the position even
further uh we have bishop to e2 uh now
at some point
black white probably will play something
like king to g2 and f4 but it's a very
unpleasant because the rook is
controlling the entire second rank
so here we have rook to b8 by firuja and
now comes king to f1 king to f1 is a
very nice prophylactic move
uh because uh well if you try something
like rook to a1 to simply chase away
this rook
black can just capture capture and then
play a knight to f3 check and the bishop
picks up the rook
so you don't want to you don't want your
king
in reach of this knight so you want to
play king to f1 and now you don't really
care about any discoveries from the
knight or the bishop
so here at knights the d7 now the bishop
also controls the the a1 square and now
knight to f3 and here uh we have queen
to
b4 you could also capture the pawn but
that's a little trick
uh hikaru plays for alireza because if
you do this then bishop to c4
and this just wins material you're going
to have to play knight rook captures and
f3 bishop captures here and you're going
to win the exchange
black's position is still very much okay
but there's no reason to do this
so instead we have queen to b4 by
alireza
and now comes bishop to c4 so just
nicely cementing everything yes this
bishop is now a pawn
but you want to stop any advancement
from black
so here rook to b8 rook bta 8 now
as there's really no breaking through
the b file and now
queen to d3 uh we have rooked the b2
now preparing to bring the other rook
over to a2 and of course
uh hikaru prepares for this he plays
rook to c2 we have rook to a2
and now he trades a pair of rooks we
have captures captures and now rook to
e1
so what do you what do you play here uh
rook backed
rook back to a2 and it's very hard for
hikaru to find an active move here he
plays bishop to b5 goes after the knight
but alireza wants to move this knight uh
either way so here knight the e5
attacking this knight which defends the
d2 square so you can bring the rook over
to d2 if the knight moves
but first knight captures an e5 bishop
captures in the now
as you know that this is coming we have
to block this so rook to e2
but now uh the a1 square is available so
rook to a1 check
king the g2 and now queen to a3 check
uh with plans of queen c1 followed by
queen to h1 checkmate as
the king will have nowhere to go so
queen to c2
not allowing this and now rook to c1
further harassing white's queen
uh we have queen to a2 and alireza again
uh
the declines the queen trade bishop back
to c4
now queen and now queen to c3 uh so what
do you play here uh you have to be again
very careful there are no good moves
here for white if you try and attack the
black queen just
queen day one and again you start
harassing the the white king
so instead after queen to c3 we have
rook to e3
uh not allowing alireza even a move so
queen back to d4
and now bishop to f1 uh so what do you
play here
king to g7 a very nice uh idea by by
ferruja he wants to start advancing
his age pawn and he doesn't want to
allow any any checks along the back ring
so
hikaru without a useful move here he
plays queen to e2
but now he vacates the a a1 square for
the black queen so queen to a1
and again what do you play here we have
queen to a6
now offering a queen trade uh but of
course alireza again declines queen to
b2
we have queen to e2 again offering a
queen trade and now
rook to c2 uh queen to f3 and now
queen to a1 not with the threat of uh
just rook to c1 so what can hikar do
here
uh he plays bishop to d3 he attacks the
rook we have rook to c1
and now comes rook to e2 the thing is if
you start with rook the g1 check and
king here you you no longer have
rook to h1 uh chugger because the queen
and the king covered that square now
so instead after rookie two we have rook
to h1 now with
idea of queen to f1 or queen to g1
checkmate
hikaru plays queen to e3 and now queen
to f1
with check we have king to f3 and now
queen captures on h3
and now it doesn't really matter what
hikaru does here there really aren't no
good moves uh at all so
uh queen to g5 was played uh not
uh not a lot to play here uh but now
comes a really
very nice idea rook to d1 so what can
you do here uh we
rook to e3 and here as the bishop is
under attack you have to play something
he carry defended
with rook to e3 but at the same moment
when he played rook to e3 he also
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh problem is uh
alireza uh can pretty much play anything
here but it's actually a forced
checkmate in four so even feel free to
pause the video and try to find
this mating idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on spotting
this checkmate in four and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to h1 with
check and now it doesn't matter where
you go because if you play something
like uh
king to g4 then this h5 check comes and
that's it you have to give up the queen
and now okay not with the pawn but you
can immediately capture with the queen
and that's mate in one
uh the white king has no squares uh and
if instead you go to e2
it's not much better because now there's
this very very uh
incredible bishop the c3 and now uh
everything is a checkmate
this is a checkmate the the the black
queen covers all of these squares the
bishop covers this so any check will be
uh just checkmate if you try and you
know block something to maybe
give a square to the kingdom rook to e1
is checkmate so there really
is no escaping this kikara knew this so
after he played rook to e3
it was uh right away in this position on
move 51 that
he resigned in the game like i said as
there is nothing more to be done here
also
one of the reasons why i chose this game
uh you know just uh
such a such a rich position with so many
pieces around the white king that is
on f3 uh a very nice final position
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said these are the
standings uh after the three days of the
preliminaries
so people who have qualified are fabiano
anish hikaru maxine uh wesley saw magnus
carlsen uh timor rajab and the ani
issues so those eight have qualified for
the main event and uh those who did not
qualify is eleven are none which is a
shame uh exact same amount of points as
yani pamisha but um
nepo with the better additional criteria
mamadara with seven and a half
ferrous and swiddler in the ding with
seven uh daniel double with six
alexander griez not
definitely not his tournament with five
and alan pisho
with one and a half points so uh there
were there are of course a lot of names
here that we would like to see on the
left but that would also mean that some
of the names from the left will be on
the right so you know uh
that's why it's uh it's a nice event not
everyone can qualify so it it means a
lot to fight
and also these are the pairings for the
first day of the knockouts uh so fabi
will face uh
uh niepo wesley so will face maxim
bashar lagrave hikaru will face magnus
and
rajab will face anishigiri so it's gonna
be a
really uh awesome and we're gonna enjoy
a lot of it so may 26th 27th will be the
quarterfinals then 28 29th will be the
semi-finals and then 30 and 31 will be
the final so
no no rest for for the wicked it would
seem
uh but yeah i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank prata
john caleb ewing mikhail volska ruben
david and trevor scott for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the main
event checking out your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day